merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
madame la ministre j'attire l'attention
du gouvernement sur les nouvelles
dispositions qui s'appliquent au
contrôle technique des véhicules
associatif assurant les services
d'urgence aux personnes
l'arrêté du 4 septembre 2010 est entrée
en vigueur le 20 mai 2018 et modifiant
celui du 18 juin 1991 pour les véhicules
dont le poids n'excède pas 3 tonnes 5 a
introduit des nouveaux points de
contrôle pour les véhicules de secours
associatif équipés d'avertisseurs
sonores et lumineux tels ceux utilisés
par la croix rouge et dans le cadre de
leur mission de premier secours aux
personnes
les modifications introduites et leur
application stricte par les opérateurs
agréés pour le contrôle technique des
véhicules légers amène ces organismes de
secours à recevoir des avis défavorables
avec pour motif défaillance majeure
en d'autres termes sans une intervention
du gouvernement
les équipements sonores et lumineux
actuellement installé sur ses véhicules
de secours de la croix-rouge ou de la
protection civile devront être retirés
ce qui aura des conséquence de
restreindre l'usagé et l'efficacité de
ces secours indispensables et de mettre
en danger la vie de nos concitoyens sans
avertisseur ils arriveront plus tard et
il sera impossible d'obtenir la priorité
sur la voie publique lors des
interventions urgentes
quelles mesures le gouvernement entend
t-il mettre en oeuvre pour permettre à
ces associations de continuer à assurer
leurs missions en cas de situation
exceptionnelle
merci la parole est à mme adam il avait
d'abord ministre a chargé transports
donne la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice proco pro cassia je voudrais
vous rassurer les règles du contrôle
technique applicable depuis le 20 mai
2018 sont entièrement compatibles avec
les caractéristiques spécifiques des
véhicules associatif assurant les
services d'urgence aux personnes
considéré en tant que véhicule l'intérêt
général ces véhicules peuvent être
équipées de feux dispositif de
signalisation complémentaires et
avertisseurs spécifique aux transports
sanitaires terrestre qui leur permettre
qui leur permettent d'assurer plus
efficacement leurs missions
ses caractéristiques techniques
particulières doivent être indiquées sur
le certificat d'immatriculation du
véhicule par la mention d'une
affectation aux transports sanitaires
lorsque cette mention est présente la
présence des équipements spécifiques
n'est pas sans sucre pas sanctionné par
le contrôle technique
si cette mention n'est pas n'existe pas
sur le certificat d'immatriculation
elle peut aussi être ajouté en
présentant le véhicule en réception à
titre isolé auprès d'une direction
régionale de l'environnement de
l'aménagement et du logement
puis en effectuant en effectuant la
demande de modification du certificat
d'immatriculation via le téléservice de
l' agence nationale des titres sécurisés
je remercie la parole est à madame
catherine cros cassia pour cinquante et
une seconde
merci madame la ministre de ces
précisions que je vais transmettre et
ils me suivent par la croix rouge est la
protection civile
qu'ils me disent que pour l'instant
sinon nous ont saisis c'est qu'on leur
refuse les contrôles techniques et il
saura t il se retrouve sans ses
possibilités sans doute à cause du
certificat d'immatriculation
je vais les inciter et j'espère
qu'effectivement ça leur permettra de
continuer à intervenir parce que nous
savons tous qu'ils sont indispensables
et qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter
des équipements ou ou d'acheter des
nouveaux véhicules
merci